violon alto ou contrebasse des
instruments que ses enfants tiennent
pour la première fois entre leurs mains
grâce au projet demos menée par la
philharmonie de paris
ces quinze jeunes plaisir oies ont reçu
leurs propres instruments si le viol
tu qu elle a transporté chez moi et
hésite parce qu'il est il pèse parce que
je laime de vidéos killers sont il faut
et imite notice j'ai déjà à prier à
faire un petit peu les instruments et
déjà appris à chanter et à danser au fur
et à mesure on apprend les notes on
apprend à jouer de l'instrument
et puis et puis à rejoindre les autres
les autres groupes c'est à dire les
flûtistes les clarinettistes durant
trois ans chaque enfant suivra quatre
heures de cours par semaine avec sa
famille d'instruments initié en 2010
demos veut démocratiser la musique
classique auprès des populations ne
disposant pas d'un accès facile à cette
pratique
c'est quelque chose qui est fort et qui
va non seulement je dirais leur
permettre de rencontrer la musique mais
aussi de faire changer leur comportement
de les accompagner dans une forme de
rigueur de joie d'optimisme et aussi de
fédération puisque ce groupe de 15 à
plaisir en contre les autres groupes de
quinze toutes les villes et donc
régulièrement et ils vont se sentir en
appartenance avec d'autres enfants c'est
important
en france une centaine de communes est
concerné par ce dispositif plus de 3000
enfants pourront découvrir
l'appartenance à un orchestre les jeunes
de plaisir participeront au grand
concert organisé avec les autres groupes
à la fin de l'année
[Musique]